what i didn't know
until i started digging into you a
little bit deeper over the past couple
days
was your own little kind of semi brush
with salazar back in
when was that like 2015 or something
like that five
2005 maybe 2005 right i read i read
david epstein's pro publica
at the time so can you explain what
happened there i mean i know it's
ancient history but it's now it
seems really kind of fresh and relevant
yeah definitely i think
um it's interesting because with all the
conversations around
whistleblowers i don't know i don't know
if i classify i don't think i do but
it's just one of those i don't really
know where my story fits in it i mean it
was a little bit of an
alarm bell sounding i think yeah it was
a harbinger of what was to come
yeah and i knew that there was an
investigation underway
i knew they were obviously digging
around in alberto's
methods and i've been thinking a lot
about that time because when that
interview with propublica started
resurfacing when the alberto salazar
thing came out and i started seeing my
name back in i was feeling
nauseous because doing that interview
was really challenging it was a tough
decision for me to do
not because i feel that i
cheated or deserve or was at risk of
i don't know it's hard to explain why it
was i guess it was just
admitting to the mindset of an athlete
trying to be the best and how you are
then vulnerable to the adults in your
life
and their um input on what it's going to
take to be the best
and that i took a small step in the
direction
and probably would have taken many more
if i had been in nike oregon project
i mean i i was like one of the most
promising
athletes in history coming out of
stanford in my event and
you know a lot of people thought i had
the kind of the complete package to
put help put distance running back on
the map i mean it's on the map now but
it wasn't when i was coming out of
college we had dina caster's
medal in um marathon and mebs and
but outside of those two little moments
we'd had nothing
right for so long and uh and that was my
whole goal was to do that and so
i came out of stanford and there was
this sort of emerging
um i don't know philosophy that was
in reaction to all the blood doping so
blood every every movement is sort of a
reaction to something else so blood
doping was becoming this big thing
um and people reading about it and then
the flip side of that was how can we
beat the cheaters without crossing the
line
like how can we outsmart the cheaters
using all the legal tools at our
disposal and this is the era
of paula radcliffe this is the era of um
alberto sells our founding nike organ
project and i really think that the
intentions at the time were
i mean he said it straight up in
interviews before we're to use every
single method on
just on this side of legal to be
competitive with
the rest of the world and to put us on
the top of the stage and that wasn't
controversial at the time
that was kind of like a oh good idea
way to use what we've got which is
science and technology and smarts
right and now when we look at it with
this
15-year lens looking back all this
concept of marginal gains and
going into gray areas is very much in
line with cheating
we're like oh that would the intent was
to
get an unfair advantage there for you
know it was against the spirit of the
sport and essentially
that's where we are now and that's where
i sit now with how i feel about it i
really feel that you shouldn't
do any of those things but yeah at the
time it wasn't i don't think it was very
clear and so i remember being in that
position of should i should i sleep in
an altitude tent
um i do have asthma and have a
prescription for an inhaler should i
take the strongest dose
possible to me um year round even if i
only need it seasonally you know like
these kind of questions of like what
where is the line and where should it be
and it does get gray and murky i mean
there's
there's on the one hand there's things
like cryotherapy and
warm-up techniques and i think you know
sleeping in an altitude tent
is kind of a standard practice for a lot
of people like i don't think people look
at that as being super controversial
um but that seems qualitatively
different
than hey uh you have a little bit of
asthma but let's trump it up and try to
get the massive dose
and use it year-round yeah just when
your symptoms flare up
exactly and so in seeking guidance for
my asthma
you know alberto was the person who knew
a doctor in portland who um had
experience
testing athletes and i believe this
doctor was a good doctor i don't think
the doctor has been it's not like the dr
brown case with thyroid this right
asthma doctor has not been implicated in
anything but and all those medications
are now legal anyway but at the time
they were
on the restricted list you had to have a
therapeutic use exemption for certain
kinds of inhalers
and yeah it was just a you know if you
went to your neighborhood
allergist they would just have you
breathe in a tube and go you don't have
asthma
you're like no really though i do and i
run
in cold weather or the 5k but they
couldn't simulate those conditions
and so you couldn't test appropriately
an exercise you know exercise induced
asthma just anywhere
so anyway that was kind of how i ended
up getting connected with alberto i was
a top nike athlete i lived in oregon
or not where did i live at the time
maybe i lived in california time anyway
i was going to be living in oregon
um but i had obviously connections to
nike headquarters and he was starting
this thing in there
out there and it was like i was like one
step removed so i had
access to some of it if i wanted it
but then i had vin linanna as my coach
who
really protected me i mean he when i
look back i'm so glad i was
under his uh guidance at the time
because
i know altitude tense are legal but it's
what an altitude tent led to at that
time so if you were sleeping in an
altitude tent all the time
and you were trying to maintain this
crazy level of training it was really
common to get run down
because you weren't sleeping as well
with altitude well once you get run down
now suddenly you can go to the doctor
that tests thyroid
and show that your thyroid is suppressed
right
because you're suddenly all your other
values are getting negatively impacted
so
i always kind of started to or i don't
always i now see the altitude tent
through nike oregon project as a kind of
a gateway
to other things and it did it
facilitated my exhaustion
really quickly yeah and it led to a
conversation with vin lanana about
thyroid because i'd heard about other
athletes and galen rep and whoever
having this thyroid problem and i was
like maybe i have a thyroid problem he's
like maybe you do
but maybe maybe you know
you're just tired because you're
training really hard and you're not
sleeping properly because you're
sleeping in this tent
maybe you need to take responsibility
for what the limits of your body are
and i was i remember feeling really
embarrassed because i remember thinking
like if i go to this doctor that these
guys are seeing i'll probably get
whatever they're getting right yeah and
i think
what's interesting about this
experience that you had is that um
i mean ultimately you had an ethical
compunction that
that allowed you to say like this is
this doesn't feel right to me like
there's
there's like what's legally okay and
then there's you know our internal kind
of barometer
around ethics and you know that flared
up for you and you were like i'm
stepping away from this this doesn't
feel right to me
but i think it speaks to how these
things happen
like we tend to you know you know from
our armchairs
uh cast aspersion and judgment on these
athletes that make
the wrong choice but we don't appreciate
the nuance of what leads up to it
because it is a very gradual slow thing
where it's one thing and then it's the
next thing and then before you know it
you've crossed that line but that line
seems imperceptible
in the moment yeah and i and that's why
in the end i decided to speak with david
epstein
because i felt that the conversations i
was hearing around
the topics of um dr brown and thyroid
stuff or the tents or the
or albertos group all the stuff i just
felt like was turning so black and white
like any athlete that could do anything
is just evil and any you know and
and i was like it's so much more complex
it is so much more complex and
i've always believed that telling
personal narrative is kind of the
is the better way to help people
understand the complexity of something
and and so i kind of offered myself out
there even though i knew it would
result in some skewering i ended up
getting a call from an old competitor
right when it came out who chewed me
out who was just like she took it as you
cheated
and this and this and like as a she
i think she took it as i had all these
other things i must not have admitted
really there was nothing else to the
story
but i remember taking that call and just
being like
okay here we go like why did i even
bother telling that story is it going to
be any good but i do think
that it helped contribute to a
conversation that
a public conversation a public
understanding it's just one of many
stories that contributes to like
the dialogue around this the importance
of really fighting for ethical and clean
sport
of learning what is and isn't okay what
we want those
that to look like in the future you know
the past is what it is but
i still do believe clean sport is
possible it's going to be hard
but it needs to be nuanced our
understanding of the past
and um yeah we rely a lot on
whistleblowers too so no one's going to
come out and talk about their
experiences if we have this
black and white view on everything right
and it's amazing
that that you shared what you shared way
back in 2005 and here we are in 2019
when this is finally getting adjudicated
and in between we have
steve magnussen when when did steve
magnus kind of
come out and publicly talk about that
l-carnitine thing that went
i think it was actually so it had this
the story i told was from 2005 but it
was probably
between 2015 and 17 that i did the
interview when it got public
and then that was similar to steve so it
was kind of around we were
all starting to tell our stories because
the rise of nike oregon project and
these
performances that seemed unbelievable
and you know this
the stories that were kind of being
circulated within distance running of
what was going on there plus some of our
personal experiences
you know i heard some of the things
about el carnitine i was like that's not
hard for me to believe
or that all these athletes are being
tested for are being treated for thyroid
conditions and the medication
helps them lose weight before race
season i'm like that's not hard to
believe
because of my experience with asthma and
my conversations with
alberto i i felt like i understood the
mindset
and so i just i i was concerned that as
the
biggest sports brand the most
influential sports brand putting their
marketing dollars behind this group and
these performances that had an ethos
that was really dangerous to clean sport
that's not okay you know and it goes all
the way to the top
the ceo being aware of the testosterone
cream and all of that
and yeah the email from salazar to lance
armstrong you know there's a lot of
stuff that you know people all the way
to the top were privy to
yeah they were and it's it's one of
those
things around innovation too i mean i
don't know if you have thought about it
from that perspective but
i think that what alberto wanted to do
with nop
was some sort of parallel to what
the innovation lab looks like for
footwear right it was
let's innovate our approach to training
and coaching just the way we would
innovate
at the fastest spike we'll look outside
the box we'll put a carbon plate in it
whatever you do
and and i think to me that explains why
there was so much conversation with
mark parker because it it's and to me
that doesn't the line between
technological innovation and other kind
of
you know less acceptable forms of moving
the needle forward
yeah got kind of um enmeshed
yeah right i think so i mean it's not
dissimilar from
the you know the the tech suits and
swimming
like it's getting weird yeah it's not
just steroids and epo
like now we're entering into gene
therapy
and all kinds of craziness where it's
gonna become even
you know it's going to become 100 fold
more difficult to try to figure out
what's fair and what's not
yeah nike it is shocking to me and i
don't know what you think
that a company like nike that spends so
much time
on branding initiatives that have to do
with the purity of the sport
you know they that i know of they have
never
taken a stand on doping like they've
never launched a brand campaign
about clean sport and only using the
body you've got
am i wrong on that what do you make of
that
well it's it is it would be completely
on brand
for them if you're looking at their
brand deck but when you look at their
marketing assets you know you've got the
nfl
mlb you know they they would
put themselves in a position to look
like the biggest hypocrites ever because
then they would have to take a stand
right if something happens then it
everyone's going to pull up that ad
campaign well yeah i mean it's all of
it's already happening i mean if you
just look at like they if they really
wanted to stand for clean sport they
could completely change
everything in a year they did do wasn't
that
um lance armstrong ad you know what am i
on i'm on my bike
that was a nike ad that was an idea
which is so ironic
so maybe you know the the uh you know
like reflecting back on that it's like
yeah maybe we shouldn't do that like
we're still talking about that
that's true but like they for example if
they decided that a major brand value
for them
was going to be clean sport they could
influence
stricter rules in major league baseball
and the nfl
around doping offenses rather than
whatever they do couple game suspension
or whatever it is in some of these cases
they could influence
i mean they could influence everything
they could they can move mountains with
the amount of money in marketing dollars
and that the level of assets
like top athletes in every sport i just
wonder what could they do if they set
their mind to it
like yeah it would be awkward and
uncomfortable at first i mean
they could clean it because they could
create like a manhattan project around
it with the resources that they have but
you know clearly it's not part of their
business plan no
and i think that you know part of that
is perhaps
a function of the fact that the way we
perceive
um doping in sports like track and field
and swimming and cycling is very
different from what it looks like in
the nfl and the nba and major league
baseball like
it it's almost like those sports get a
pass like we don't really
every once in a while there's the a-rod
kind of situation
but i can't imagine what's actually
going on there that just gets
you know unnoticed so
there is a disparity in the way that we
think about um
doping in sports in those various
disciplines
there is and they're the kind of i guess
that's what i mean by
they're sort of the common player in all
of them so if you were going to make
sweeping change culturally
i don't know who else could do it
they certainly have the marketing muscle
to be able to create impact
in anything that they decide to focus
[Music]
yeah